[Música]
ya lo decía en directo a vamos ahora
eeuu donde el congreso estatal de
virginia occidental aprobó aprobó
prohibir la interrupción voluntaria del
embarazo con excepción sólo en casos de
violación incesto y riesgo para la vida
de la madre y este retroceso para los
derechos reproductivos se suma a un
proyecto de ley que presentó al senador
republicano lindsey graham para
penalizar el aborto a partir de la
semana 15 a nivel nacional con contadas
excepciones
conectamos con cristóbal vázquez
corresponsal en la capital
estadounidense
cristóbal que otros detalles se conocen
de esta normativa aprobada en virginia
occidental y de del proyecto de ley y
porque cobra tanta importancia el tema
del aborto a pocos meses de las
elecciones de medio término
de lirio occidental se convierte en el
segundo estado en aprobar leyes que
prohíban el aborto después de la
decisión de la corte suprema de justicia
de no reconocer precisamente el aborto
como un derecho
constitucional el aborto entonces en
virginia occidental que se podría hacer
antes de las 20 semanas ahora sería
prohibido y sólo en casos de incesto
violación o riesgo de la vida de la
madre se podrá hacer este se podrá hacer
se podrá abortar pero sólo dentro de las
primeras ocho semanas
esta ley entra en vigor en 90 días y
varios republicanos han reaccionado
diciendo que es muy laxa y que también
está esta medida en virginia occidental
precisamente cuando el insee graham hace
el anuncio de que va a presentar un
proyecto de ley para que a nivel federal
se prohíba el aborto después de las 15
semanas esto en una época que ya se
considera en eeuu como
los principios de las campañas de las
campañas para las legislativas en
noviembre y es importante porque en las
encuestas pues este tema del aborto está
haciendo que pues mucha gente muchas
mujeres sobre todo se registren para
votar y va a ser sin duda el tema
central para demócratas y republicanos
bueno y otro tema que concentra la
atención en eeuu es la muerte de ken
starr el fiscal que investigó el affaire
entre el entonces presidente presidente
bill clinton y la entonces pasante
monica lewinsky háblenos de este
personaje
sí y de hecho su mujer alice estar no
quiso revelar las causas de su muerte
simplemente dijo que la complicación en
su
operación llevó a la muerte de star star
fue el fiscal que pues destapó este
escándalo de lewin ski y clinton cuando
bill clinton era presidente y llevó al
impeachment de él el ex presidente era
el primer en pitch mente en ese entonces
después de 130 años y el impeachment era
precisamente por obstrucción a la
justicia y por por el falso juramento
ante la justicia que resaltar también
que después de estar fue abogado de
donald trump y también de jeffrey
epstein en los casos de abuso sexual a
menores